at least two people and an armed
attacker have been killed in New
Zealand's biggest city Auckland several
others are injured in the attack which
happened hours before the city was due
to Stage the opening of the FIFA Women's
World Cup the suspected gunman stormed a
building under renovation in the central
business district he's believed to have
been a worker at the construction site
the assessment from officials is that
there is no National Security risk
there is no change to New Zealand's
National Security Threat Level
this is the information that we're able
to share so far
the offender was armed with a pump
action shotgun
he moved through the building site
discharging the firearm as he went
upon reaching the upper levels of the
building the man contained himself in an
elevator
shots were fired and he was located a
short time later
Al jazeera's Andrew Thomas reports from
Auckland
that building with the crane on top of
it is the one in which this shooting
took place at about 7 20 in the morning
Auckland time now that building is a
construction site at the moment nearly
finished but not quite so no office
workers in there but plenty of
construction workers many of whom fled
to the top the roof of that building
while this shooting was underway police
were on the scene within about 15-20
minutes and this shootout between the
police and the gunman then took place
Thursday should have been should still
be a very proud day for New Zealand the
start of the Women's World Cup it begins
here in Auckland later on Thursday and
the world media was here to cover that
you can see lots of journalists on the
edge of that court and their Sports
journalists mostly instead covering a
shooting in what is New Zealand's
biggest city and a major area of the
central business district of Auckland
locked off hours after the shooting took
place